this year's lecturer silly down here is
Professor Lina fedorov she is the
Willimon professor of life sciences in
the evan pugh professor of biology
department and Huck instituted life
sciences at Penn State and she's an
external professor Santa Fe Institute
Nina received her bachelor's degree in
Syracuse University in biology chemistry
in 1966 and a PhD from the Rockefeller
University in molecular biology of 1972
and she's held faculty positions at UCLA
the Carnegie Institution in Washington
and a Johns Hopkins in 1990 Nina was
alleged the National Academy of Sciences
in 2002 far greater order the european
academy sorry how Nina's research
contributions have been principally in
the era of genetics with a focus on
jumping genes and transpose whether
you're hell down tomorrow and in
particular the relationship of his
peculiar genes to plant development
disease more recently in has been
working with mathematicians and
physicists on quantifying the network's
underlying gene expression in 1992 with
authority Authority President hina
committed a Vorlon called the dynamic
genome Barbara McClintock ideas in the
centre of genetics and this was a volume
that commemorated McClintock to truly
revolutionary contributions pathology
she would have no
1983 and I mentioned clean job because I
think the intellectual influence has
been quite strong on Nina's career than
set of interests I'm in particular both
McClintock panting have been very
interested in obsessed I'd say we're how
genomes respond to stress so when
they're stressed have a reconfigure how
they evolve how they died it was this
sort of complex systems perspective our
genomes which is quite contrary to usual
linear sequencing of nucleotides that
really endeared her and attracted us to
her and perhaps hurt and Santa Fe
Institute how and then the first 19 in
2004 sorry Nancy brown she wrote a
popular book on a slightly more
controversial topic will return to on
the third later on genetically modified
foods called men in the kitchen now I
have to confess and apologize city and
east as a young man I wish found plants
rather dull and I think there's
something to do with the indicate
brussel sprouts and of course is the
British cuisine and I've certainly never
heard about its water but I think
there's something about animals tigers
and Tyrannosaurus that may be
intrinsically more alluring like trains
and then reflect your American main
differences is
all strikers are so dynamic and plants
at least to our very primitive
perceptual apparatus seem very static so
the clods don't seem to move very much
the valency to feel sea life and I think
in today's lecture is insurance when
they showed me how wrong we've been fat
unlike animals and how the nervous
system we're interconnected neurons that
allowing us back to behave plants have a
more diffuse chemical network where many
of these reductions of interest occur
within the set itself so that's what
we're going to hear about today another
system applies tomorrow Nina will focus
on the genetics and jumping genes and as
I said before the final way she will
discuss genetically modified foods the
first two evenings Nina will field
questions has served and I mean finally
only three will have the oprah winfrey
set up well Alan did you mean for one
and you'll be free to jump in should be
very commendable exciting so this is
between fastening the three sets of
nature's table
so thank you David for that lovely
introduction but it was longer than
three minutes and thank you all for
coming I hope that over the next three
evenings I can provide you with some
chewy entertainment about plants and
jeans I think if you have the patience
to stay with it and stick through the
three lectures you'll have a new
appreciation of the marvelous organisms
on which we humans have built our
civilizations but I hope too that you'll
understand enough about genes and
genomes a genetic modification of crops
so that you're better able to judge the
merits of the controversy about
genetically modified foods there's a
profoundly important issue in the world
today and hugely contentious so my first
title promises that I will tell you how
plants see feel and smell plants of
course David don't have eyes or noses or
nervous systems or a brain like animals
do I have a very different lifestyle and
animals they don't shop in grocery
stores they don't catch other animals
for food all those you'll see some
plants aren't above snacking on an
insect occasionally instead they use the
sun's energy to make food out of thin
air and water since sunlight and air are
pretty abundant plants generally don't
need to be able to run around I'll have
to catch other plants don't have to
avoid them and yet as surely as animals
plants constantly monitor their
environment and adjust to it plants
perceive and respond to light they
assess the amount and the quality of
light they even monitor daily indeed
they know when to flower by how long the
days and they have built-in day-night
cycles just like animals do plants
perceive and respond to physical stimuli
these include wind
hail he also respond to chewing insects
and biting animals plants respond to
chemicals in the environment including
gases they also detect and respond to
chemicals produced by microorganisms
such as bacteria and fungi and they talk
to each other using chemicals finally
plants know up from down they sense and
respond to gravity so let's start with
touch plants respond to being touch in
many different time scales sometimes the
speed of their responses matches our
time scale and sometimes it doesn't the
fastest reactions of plants are called
nastic responses that cumbersome
technical name for responding fast to
touch is fig bond st the first film clip
shows how a mimosa plant responds in
this case it this happens with touch but
it also happens in this case with a
little bit of heat if you've ever had
one of these plants you know that the
that the response spreads to the
adjacent leaves and if you just lit a
bit the whole front collapses the
response is electrically triggered in
the response is caused by the rapid
release of water from certain cells if
you don't touch the plant again for a
while it will recover in a few minutes
and be ready to respond again now here's
another familiar example the Venus
flytrap this plant has highly modified
leaves they're just poised to trap
insects if you touch the leaf just the
right way it's snaps shut let's look at
how that happens there are special
specialized hairs right in the middle of
this modified leaf you see them here and
when they're touched several times in a
succession as as a fly might do walking
on the leaf it snaps shut just as you
saw before almost like pricking a
water-filled balloon that in turn starts
a slower response so all of these things
happen by cells on one side of the of
the leaf swelling and the other side
shrinking
so that very fast response starts a
slower response that ends up sealing
that chamber around the insect and then
eventually the the plant secretes
enzymes and actually digestion and
absorbs the nutrients from the from the
insect that it has tracked the important
point here is there are they're both
fast responses and slower responses
which actually restructure the leaf now
here's a plant with a slightly different
strategy for trapping insects this is a
species of the sundew family there are
lots of different ones and they don't
have very well-developed roots so they
actually get most of their nutrients
from catching flies this is actually a
modified leaf and it's covered with
structures called trichomes trichomes
are actually very familiar that's what
makes a tomato leaf for example feel
fuzzy these are very special trichomes
because they secrete a little drop of
moisture at the very tip they're called
secret or e trichomes here's a close-up
of them now the stuff they secrete is
very sticky and insects landing on this
leaf get stuck in the stuff that's one
of the ways that actually plants defend
themselves this particular plant
actually traps the insects them and
absorbs the nutrients from them but
there are lots of plants that actually
use this as an insect defense response
so what then happens is that a little
bit more slowly once the fly is stuck
the touching induces the leaf to curl
around it and then like the Venus
flytrap the plant secretes enzymes in
and absorbs the nutrients so this then
slower response to touch is called figma
tropism a tropism is a change in how a
plant grows the signal part of this big
word simply means the change happens in
response to touch
now but a change in in what here I need
to explain a curious phenomenon called
nutation it's a funny term that's
applied to the motions of plants in of
planets notation is a nodding motion
it's used to denote a slight wobble in
the axis of planets in the axis of
rotation but here's what it looks like
for plants you know time lapse this is a
time-lapse movie the previous ones were
in real time the photos were actually
taken about every 15 minutes it takes
about an hour to make a complete circuit
here's another example of sunflower
ceilings this is not a response to light
this is constant light
see what you didn't know
okay so this is actually not a movement
it's a displacement in space caused by
differential growth now imagine this
thing here that looks like a tree trunk
is really a slender stem of one of those
seedlings that you just can see in the
other photographs in fact it's magnified
many many times so that each one of
those square oblong objects on its
outside is a single cell now imagine
further that there's a wave of faster
growth that sweeps around the
circumference of the stem so that each
column of cells in turn grows faster for
a few minutes and then slows down the
growth rate oscillates the result is
just what you saw in the video clips the
tip of the plant keeps moving its
location around in a circle roots do
exactly the same thing in soil what
causes this oscillatory growth is not at
all well understood it's an unsolved
problem begging for a mathematician to
look at it it goes back to Charles
Darwin it's an innate property of plant
growth and it's very important for both
shoots and roots here's a video clip and
in this one you will first see the
nutation movement of Morning Glory vines
that you didn't know that was going on
in your garden either but watch what
happens when one of the tendrils hits a
stick
that's the moat rope ism the growth
pattern changes abruptly in response to
touch beans and peas and grapes and
wisteria anything that climbs is doing
the same thing this is undoubtedly what
Jack's beanstalk was doing while he was
sleeping but the fairy tale doesn't tell
us what it was that it was climbing up
now this motion is equally important
fruits if not more important because
it's the combination of the nutation in
the thigma tropism that allows them to
grow through the soil particles there's
one even slower response to touch the
technical term for it is fig mo
morphogenesis big mo now you know is
about touch morphogenesis is about
development here is a photograph that
shows a bunch of plants this is a rabid
opsys which many plant biologists use
today as a model plant and the only
difference was that the tall ones
weren't touched and the short ones were
touched twice a day how many years ago
when I was growing corn indoors in a
special growth chamber the corn plants
used to grow so tall that we had to
climb ladders to pollinate them no
famous geneticist but in Barbara
McClintock you've already heard her name
tonight and you heard more about her in
the next lecture came to visit my
laboratory and I showed her these
incredibly tall plants she immediately
grabbed one and chicken they need wind
she said and exactly how plants perceive
the stress and strain of physical
stimuli is not well understood but just
as the stress and strain of physical
stimuli strengthens your bones and
muscles physical strengthens physical
stresses also strengthen plants and can
sculpt them in interesting ways here in
fact is a tree the wind isn't blowing
but it the wind in this particular
location has sculpted the way the tree
grew
let's move on now to how plants perceive
light here are some germinating seeds
they send out a route first and then a
shoot but they're usually way down deep
in the soil the first thing they do is
grow as fast as possible looking for
light these are seedlings that are
actually filmed under at a wavelength
that they can't see so they think it's
the dark and you can see that they grow
very tall they never turn green the very
same seedlings growing in light look
very different their leaves open their
much shorter and there they are new
tating this is called photo
morphogenesis the pattern of growth in
light the pattern of growth in dark is
called scotto morphogenesis pattern of
growth and dark plants have proteins
called fighter groans which sense light
and communicate information about how
much light there is the quality of it
and its duration the light is directly
absorbed I apologize this particular
diagram is almost invisible but the
light is directly absorbed by these
little chemical groups they're called
chromophores and they're attached to
larger molecules proteins the PR form of
this particular phytochrome is inactive
when it absorbs light it changes its
shape and becomes active maybe this will
be more obvious it's like a switch the
fright of chrome reverts to its active
state when it is exposed to far red
light these are the absorption spectra
and you can see that the PRF form has a
peak in the red portion of the spectrum
and the pfr form has a peak in the far
red portion of the spectrum there are a
number of different versions of this
phytochrome as well as other light
sensing proteins which absorb light of
varied
wait Lex now let's go down to the level
of cells themselves and see how the
phytochromes work animals have
specialized cells and specialized organs
the eyes for detecting light plants
actually see light with all of their
cells here's the very magnified view of
a stem I showed you earlier in these
elongated structures the lumps on the
outside are single cells so let me
amplify those magnify those a bit more
these are actually onion skin cells that
are expressing a protein that fluoresce
is green and it's just a way of marking
different structures in the cell which
otherwise wouldn't be visible so here's
the membrane that's inside of the cell
wall plant cells are inside of boxes
that's why they look square there's the
nucleus and that's where the genes
reside that's the information repository
you'll hear great deal more about that
in my next lecture but the in central
point here is that information that the
plant doesn't need at that moment is
stored in the genes in the nucleus and
when it's needed it is read out and the
phytochromes mediate that process so
here's an even larger view of a cell the
phytochromes in general when there is no
light form clumps around the nucleus
when light is perceived the phytochromes
move into the nucleus and activate the
genes that the that the cell needs to
respond and grow in a very different way
now without light a plant a seedling
can't get off the ground it has only the
reserves in the seed of starch to
survive on so it's a at a premium to
find sunlight when it finds light it can
begin to make its own food from air and
water plants also respond to light quite
quickly by changing the direction of
growth watch this blue light was shined
from this direction to the
at these seedlings that were growing in
the dark that change actually happens
over a period of just a few hours this
is called phototropism not surprising by
this time the change is relatively rapid
in the next video you'll see corn
seedlings that had been growing in the
dark and these the light was switched on
and then the filming began again these
are time-lapse movies the plants appear
to be worshiping the light bowing to the
light but you see that when the light is
turned on the larger light is turned on
the plants straighten up this is
actually not an immediate motion it's a
change in the way the plant is growing
now when the plants straighten up that's
actually a response to both light and
gravity and we'll get to gravity in a
moment but first let's go back to some
really old experiments to see what's
happening here to cause the plants to
curve the way they do these are
experiments that go all the way back to
Darwin discovered that the curvature of
the platte shoots in response to light
was controlled actually by a substance
that traveled down from the tip of the
plan if you remove the very tip as you
can see here it doesn't show up too well
I think well enough in any event if this
is basically a little grass seedling and
around it around the first true leaves
there's a little sheath that's called
the coleoptile and it's the thing that
senses the light so if you remove the
tip it no longer bent if he covered the
tip with an opaque cap that wouldn't let
any light through it wouldn't bend but
if he covered it with a transparent tip
it would bend but it was important to
cover the tip of the plant if he
actually covered the base that's shown
here
it's still bent now many years later
some further experiments were done so
basically these experiments showed that
it was light and it was something coming
from the tip of the plant that had to
travel in order to induce the curvature
now further experiments showed that you
could actually separate the tip from the
rest of it if the separating medium was
actually permeable like gelatin to the
chemicals than the bending occurred if
it wasn't this is a microchip then the
bending didn't occur so these experience
established that both light and movement
of some chemical down the chute is
necessary chemical was eventually
identified and it's called in oxon now
we can combine the insights from these
old experiments with some very new
information about photoreceptors and
oxen transporters to understand what's
going on here what's actually going on
is when the light strikes from one side
is perceived by photo tropin at the very
tip and that stimulates auxin transport
from the tip down but more on one side
and away from the light then on the
other side light is perceived by blue
light receptors called photo tropin they
are that their location is highlighted
by the green fluorescent protein
basically what people do is they attach
a protein to one of these green
fluorescent markers and then the green
fluorescent marker follows the protein
and shows people exactly whether the
protein is located in the cell very
clever trick so you can see that all the
outsides of the cells these are actually
in the membranes but in all of the
membranes those are the sensing the
light sensors now the reason that auxins
move directionally is because the oxen
transporters are all in the bottoms of
the cells you can see that
you can't sell bottom from top but
you'll have to take my word for it for a
month for the moment so the auxin
transport is downward because the
proteins that pump the oxygen out of the
cells are located in the membranes at
the bottom so they can only transport
them now these oxen transporters got a
funny name they're called pin proteins
and that's short for pin I'd the reason
they're called that is because the they
were originally identified in a mutant
that failed simply failed to grow leaves
and all it did was to make a pin
therefore it's called pin oi that tells
you that the auxins are extremely
important for all aspects of plant
growth now how is it that auxins work
this is the oxygen molecule it is a
small simple molecule let's related to
an amino acid tryptophan and there's
actually a number of different oxidants
but this is probably the most active one
it has a big effect on the expression of
certain genes now you don't know about
genes much about genes yet but again all
we need to know for this purpose is that
there the information repository and
that information is read out in much the
way you make a copy of something on a
copying machine now these genes are
controlled the genes that response to
auxins by activators but on top of that
they are inhibited from working by
repressors that stick to the activated
proteins now you'd think that the oxen
would would interact directly with this
complex but it actually doesn't what it
does is interact with a complex machine
of a multiprotein machine that actually
degrades proteins and when the oxen
enters the cell it actually binds to one
of the members of that big complex and
activates it to actually degrade the
repressor now that sounds like an
obscure way to activate a gene
and there it is doing its thing making a
copy of the DNA but that is in part in
large measure the way that plants stay
poised to respond so rapidly to changing
conditions so the the switch in the
scrotal morphogenesis to photo
morphogenesis dark growing too late grow
growing pattern works much the same way
so the important point here is that the
molecular systems are always poised it
seems like an inefficient system but it
poises them to respond immediately to
changing conditions by reprogramming how
the plant is growing so now we come to
how it is that plants know up from down
their ability to sense and respond to
gravity now inside each of these sees
these are corn seeds corn kernels is a
tiny plant embryo maybe you've noticed
when you're eating sweet corn that
there's a kind of slippery shield-shaped
small thing in every kernel that's
actually the baby plant for the next
generation now remarkably whether you
plant this plant these seeds right side
down or upside down the roots grow down
and the shoots grow up
now if you take a route this is a corn
root again that's growing down and turn
it on its side within hours this is not
in real time this is time lapse but
their photographs are taken about five
minute intervals so within several hours
that reorientation is complete and the
roots are growing down again now the
opposite thing happens with shoes not
surprisingly that's the roots growing
down is called positive gravitropism and
the shoots going up is negative
gravitropism as I said it's fast but not
instantly these are time-lapse movies
the change in the origin group begins to
be seen within half an hour and it's as
I said complete with that a couple of
hours this happens with plants of all
ages as long as they're still growing I
remember once when I was doing corn
genetics in Missouri a tornado almost
touched down in our field we emerged
from our work shed five heart-stopping
minutes later to find the entire
cornfield flattened but it had been
raining a lot so the plants weren't
broken and within a day the plants had
all stood up again but of course the
wind had stirred them so they all came
up in a confused mess which was a
geneticist nightmare the roots ability
to sense gravity is in the very tip of
the root whose structures shown here I
should note that although I've said
these are federal flab pictures if the
pictures are not a scrubbed they're from
my lab every other every picture that I
have borrowed from someone else is
acknowledge the sources acknowledged
here's a higher magnification view of
that root tip and it has actually two
parts to it there's a root cap and
that's kind of highlighted here by the
expression of a gene
that turns a particular substrate blue
but it's only expressed in the root cap
the root cap as the roots growing is
actually Slough doff and it's constantly
regrowing now even within that root cap
there's a specialized set of cells
called called the collumela cells here's
a diagram of the whole thing that's
these collumela cells that actually
sense gravity the ones that are right in
the middle highlighted here right in
here you can see little granules in this
picture in these cells and if you Staind
those granules with iodine which turns
starch black you can see that those are
all little starch granules there's
simply little starch pub pebbles and
they're called stato lists when a root
is turned on its side the starch
granules relocate the new bottom is
defined by the gravitational vector now
here I've Illustrated my point using a
primitive root called a rise I'd
produced by certain kind of allergy LG
the situation and a plant is a little
more complicated but it's much the same
so here's an Arab adopts this room Arab
adopts this is the favorite experimental
plant today and it shows that the Axum
which is moving down the plant I showed
that to you in very young seedlings but
what happens in the root is it that the
flow turns around and goes back up and
that's illustrated by the arrows here
now if you turn the plant on its side I
think I should use this if you turn the
plan on its side then as in the shoot
oxen begins to be transported more
rapidly on that side then on that then
on the on the upper side than the lower
side and the more oxen is flowing
through the cells the faster they grow
so the faster the upper side grows
faster than the lower side and of course
that bends the root down
so what's happening down at the level of
cells is kind of this the oxen is being
pumped into the cells and out of the
cells all the time in the direction of
gravity the molecules that pump it in
are called oxen influx carriers and
they're located at the temps I think you
can see that a little more clearly this
is kind of a greenish fluorescence and
you don't see anything at the bottom of
the cell here's the bottom but they're
at the top the orcs and II flux carriers
as I told you before at the bottom of
the cell and here's a photograph again
these are fluorescing and you can see
that the that it's at the very bottom in
and by contrast to what's here so
there's a constant movement through the
plants and what happens at the level of
the so these are the proteins that do
the job some of them drive the oxen down
others drive it back up again through
the outside layers what's happening it
and this is a little oversimplified but
what's happening at the level of the
cell is that the little starch granules
slowly migrated to the bottom of the new
bottom of the cell just under the
influence of gravity that results in the
destruction or the recycling of the
influx and II flux carriers and then
they are reinserted in the new bottom
and top of the cell and so now the cell
it's turned on its side it has a new
bottom and a new top and that basically
reorients how the the whole organ grows
same thing happens in the shoots there
little starch granules but the
reorientation is in the opposite
direction we don't really understand why
it goes in one direction in roots and
the other direction in shoots so that's
how plants know up from down
now the last thing I promised to tell
you about is about how plants smell how
they perceive stuff in the air this is a
very big subject and I will only skim
the surface I think the most important
thing for you to know is that plant is
what is a bit about what plants do with
gases particularly carbon dioxide so let
me introduce you to the central engine
of life as it were on earth the
chloroplast all these little green
lozenges are chloroplasts that's what
makes plants green if you take the cell
wall off of a plant cell it still has a
membrane but it rounds up because it's
no longer constrained this is such a
cell and what you see are the little
chloroplasts around the edges now the
interesting thing is that part of the
light that's absorbed the chloroplasts
are green because they absorb light of a
certain wavelength they emit part of it
and if you irradiate with the right
wavelength and observe the fluorescence
you they look red and that's evident
here now there's an arrow at the nucleus
will talk about the nucleus tomorrow for
the moment I'm focusing on chloroplasts
now what happens in chloroplasts that's
so magical well a corpus is actually a
pretty complicated structure and I've
called it the engine of life on earth
what chloroplasts do is take carbon
dioxide and water and then use the sun's
energy to convert those simple molecules
into the complicated sugar molecules and
oxygen the technical name for this is
photosynthesis its sheer magic mix
carbon dioxide try this at home mix
carbon dioxide in water the fizzy stuff
in your drinks is carbon dioxide add
sunlight and outcomes sugar you can't do
it
but these little critters can it matters
not at all whether you're a vegetarian
and eat only plants directly or a
meat-eater who eats meat from animals
who eat plants all of your energy comes
from photosynthesis it what it's what
ties us to the earth what happens inside
the chloroplast is that energy that the
light energy that it's absorbed is used
to energize electrons the extra energy
is then gradually extracted to power the
chemical reactions that build the
complicated sugar molecules but in fact
this is a dangerous business the
chloroplast can't turn off the Sun its
energy source there's too much light for
the rest of the ingredients in
photosynthesis the excited electrons
don't have anywhere to go it's a bit
like controlling a nuclear reactor
everything has to be in balance or the
system gets out of control plants have
many ways of controlling the electron
flow and chloroplasts but if they're
overwhelmed it can kill the plant you
perhaps have the experience of bringing
an indoor plant outdoors and watching
all of its leaves turn brown and die
usually doesn't kill the plant that's
death by sunburn indoors the light level
is very low and the plant adjusts its
light-collecting capacity to that low
light level the sudden increase in the
amount of light excites too many
electrons for them to deal with and the
electrons escape directly into oxygen
generating what is called reactive
oxygen species reactive oxygen species
are simply oxygen molecules that are
collecting extra electrons on their way
to becoming water but they haven't
gotten there yet and they're very eager
to egg to grab extra electrons that's a
strong oxidizing agents these can damage
cells they do damage to animal cells
they do damage to plant cells actually a
familiar reactive oxygen species is
hydrogen peroxide which is often used to
sterilize to kill bacteria in wounds
it's not a very strong one
so it's incredibly important for plants
to regulate their gas and water supplies
perhaps you've gone on vacation and come
back to see some of your house plants in
this condition well if you're lucky you
weren't away too long and when you
wanted the plant comes back plants pull
water out of the earth like pulling
drink up through a straw then they
control how much of it is released
through the leaves most of the leaf
surface is very well sealed coated with
waxy stuff that doesn't less moisture
out or guess is in but on the bottom of
the leaf shown here there are some small
openings through which gases enter and
water escapes it's a very highly
magnified view of just the very surface
layer from the bottom the epidermis from
the bottom of a leaf it's covered with
cells that look like jigsaw puzzle
pieces but there are some here and there
there's some curved cells that surround
a little hole the whole structure is
called a stow mate these open and close
here's a picture of a closed one to
regulate the uptake of carbon dioxide
and the release of water let's take a
closer look here's the stow mate and it
consists of two cells called guard cells
these get bigger and smaller by taking
in water or pushing it out it's largely
an electrical phenomenon like inflating
analogous inflating an inner tube or
letting air out of it there are
chloroplasts in all of these cells now
remember chloroplasts fluoresce red and
what I've done here is just super
imposed semi-transparent detection of
the same cells at the wavelength that
the chloroplasts in it so you can see
that there are chloroplasts in the
pavement cells in their chloroplasts in
the in the guard cells they make little
rings in
the ones in the guard cells make little
rings now what I'm going to show you now
is that these card cells are very very
sensitive sensors that respond to
changing conditions not only by changing
their shape and controlling gas access
but they actually signal to the
neighboring cells and start the entire
response of the plant to the conditions
the first line messenger is in fact
precisely those reactive oxygen species
that form in the chloroplasts when
something is out of whack and
photosynthesis is disrupted what I'll
show you here is what happens when the
leaves are exposed to own zone which is
a very corrosive form of oxygen and it's
a major air pollutant it has detrimental
effects on plants if there's too much of
it in fact it can it can make the leaves
turn brown and drop off in the
experiment I'll sure the plants were
exposed to 350 parts per billion of
ozone and that's a level that is not
untypical for major metropolitan areas
in the summertime it is very detrimental
some class but this particular plant can
tolerate it and actually adjust to
respond to it now I've superimposed the
layer of that shows you the location of
the chloroplast ignore these these are
just stuff from adjacent cell layers
that didn't get removed what you can see
is that there are there are chloroplasts
in these big pavement cells and they're
these little rings of chloroplasts in
the guard cells what we did is to expose
the plants briefly to ozone and then add
a dye that only flores's and it will
fluoresce green when it's oxidized so it
marks the site of where the reactive
oxygen species are produced and so now
I'll replace this layer that shows all
of the chloroplasts with a layer that
shows
where the reactor reactive oxygen
species are produced if I take away that
bottom layer of cells what you can see
is that you have little circles of
fluorescing chloroplasts specifically in
the guard cells now if you come back 15
minutes later that happens within
minutes if you come back 15 minutes
later what you see is fluorescence
especially in the membranes in cells
that are immediately around those guard
cells what's happening is that the
chloroplasts are sending a signal to the
cell membrane where there's an enzyme
that shoots electrons across the
membrane to generate more reactive
oxygen species outside of the cell and
that's a signal that alerts the next
cell and excites its enzymes to do the
same thing the signal then travels to
and through the next cell to the next
cell to the next cell alerting it to
trouble and spreading the word that
times are bad and you need to change
what you're doing and specifically shut
down photosynthesis now we've also
analyzed so if you come back another
half hour later what you can see as big
patches of fluorescing cells again
propagating the signal we've looked at
what the genes are doing in not
surprisingly because the plant can't
turn off the Sun what it can do is it's
turn off the genes that encode the
proteins that actually collect the light
so those are turned down and what's
turned up is genes that code for
proteins that help it deal with stress
and mop up precisely these reduce these
reactive oxygen species now if the
system is not completely overwhelmed it
adjusts that stress comes back and is
not damaged but of course if you up the
concentration of ozone eventually you'll
kill the cells because it can't handle
that amount of damage so it so has a
certain range within which it can adjust
same thing happens when you increase the
light level precisely the same thing
the chloroplasts and the guard cells
begin to produce reactive oxygen species
communicating with with next to herself
so now finally before I've put you
completely to sleep you want to show you
one last thing and that is that plants
like people have sleep-wake cycles these
plants are actually in constant light
and this is an innate property of the
plant the technical name for it is a
circadian rhythm these changes in how
the leaf is held our consequence of how
the water pressure is maintained in
certain cells you saw an illustration of
the rapid changes in water pressure very
early in my lecture in plants as in
people circadian rhythms are part of how
the plant works you know it from your
own experience of jetline you tend to
get sleepy at the same time and wake up
at the same time as you did in your own
time zone when you're transported
rapidly to another time so that as your
body rhythm is out of step with the new
day light cycle day/night cycle and
adjust only gradually over a period of
days the same thing happens in plants if
you were to be put in either continuous
darkness or continuous light these
rhythms would persist for a considerable
time that is although they are keyed to
the day/night cycle they're part of your
makeup that's true of plants as well
here are plants in complete darkness
defined as a light of a wavelength that
they can't perceive and you can see that
they undergo their leaf collapse and
leaf extension
and in plants as in animals these cycles
are normally keyed the technical term is
entrained to the light-dark cycle now
just how these rhythms are set up and
keyed to the data cycle is a very
exciting current area of research in
both plants and animals and not well
understood yet well that's it for
tonight tomorrow's talk will be about
sex jeans jeans the jump and jeans that
don't will talk about genomes that's the
name for the entire collection of genes
in the organism and we'll talk about how
genomes evolved and how our ideas about
how genes and genomes evolved in our
structure have changed over the course
of the 20th century so that's the
business end of the plan to come back
and hear about it tomorrow night and I
would be delighted to answer any
questions that you might have
yes Lance feel pain at all of you Claude
would kill the plant how would you
define them unpleasant sensation they
don't have a nervous system they don't
have that the kind of apparatus that
animals do they respond chemically when
you cut a plant when a insect chews on a
plant they certainly respond they fight
back they have a good chemical arsenal
especially to fight back at joining
insects but pain is you define it is a
function of your brain it's implants
don't have brains yes
the question is what is it that that
gets the shtetl list to tumble down to
the bottom of the cell they're dense
there it's a very dense de position
actually though starch granules are
relatives of chloroplasts but the plant
continues to deposit starch it's a
storage it's the store starch and those
is those little granules as well but yes
they don't move all that fast and
remember that a cell is in the sack of
water it's a very viscous medium so this
doesn't happen very rapidly yes what is
the major difference between water and
plants on the surface plant under water
plants there are many many differences
they don't have the same architecture as
as largely the reason that they're very
different in structure is because they
don't have to hold themselves up in
other words they're buoyed up in a
medium just as you are when you go
swimming and they don't need these
complicated structures in this very
strong stem and so forth too but the
photosynthetic apparatus is is there and
so they're related but they don't have
the complexity of the most highly
evolved land plants ok let me get
somebody in the back because it's easier
to call on people in front than in bath
tipsy lots and time initially in fact
releasing a chemical signal because
other plants narratives are not being
attacked to change the makeup of their
self yes plants do communicate I hope
everybody heard that but i think the
essence of the question the statement
was that there are when when plants are
injured they release chemicals some of
them gases that affect the response of
neighboring plants indeed that my
comment is that it is correct in fact
some of the things that we find
wonderful perfumes jasmonic acid the
smell of jasmine which we find extremely
pleasant is actually an alarm hormone in
implants yes
plans take sound
Oh vibration yes but not sound in the
sense of your perceptual apparatus but
certainly it is that its vibration and
if you blast a plant with sound I
suspect that it will grow like it would
if you touched it oh I knew that was
somebody's going to ask that one I don't
want you to stop talking nice to your
plans well probably you're carrying a
watering can when you're talking I would
guess that the water would do them more
good than the talking and if you put you
know a few minerals in the water that
they like it even better I'm sorry
function besides
oh yes they are generally used within
the plant there are their gaseous
hormones in people their gaseous
hormones in plants most convenient one
is ethylene but jasmonic acid actually
triggers a major part of the stress
response major adaptations turns on some
jeans turns off other genes basically
plants remember so they have memory even
if they don't hear things so that these
changes that occur in response to
stresses which are triggered by
chemicals like jasmonic acid actually
persists for quite a long time and make
the plant more resistant to further
insult okay where have I not called
here's one then I'll come back down
front I'll come back down front next
herbs or something but they would go up
really nasty 30 conceived it is scary
stuff in there three whole days and take
this but well enlighten my desk by off I
first was a good for the planet this is
moving Admiral concerts in humans so
that when people get it
they carry the pond somewhere else no
most I don't know what particular
chemical you're referring to but but you
know most of the drugs that are
hallucinates in in people our client of
plant origins do they do the same thing
implants no but they're part of the
chemical or are some so plants make
carcinogens they make toxic compounds
they have a large personal they can't
run away but they can fight back and
that's something that we have to always
remember there are lots of plants
they're toxic to people okay there are
plants that produce hallucinogens there
are plants that produce toxins there are
plants that produce medicines that
interaction that that's chemistry okay
and plants do make many many what
they're called secondary metabolites and
that's part of what people are searching
for in plants that are less well studied
than our familiar plans yes ladies first
right now we're one end of the cell they
said another end series it looks
superficial
this is certainly the case that plant
membranes like animal membranes are
polarized they do change the
permeability properties so there's that
analogy works but they don't have
neurons okay so that pumping it may it
accomplishes perhaps the same thing but
the mechanism is different furthermore
what remember that there's not a
circulatory system but there is this
polarized transport there's a vascular
system but not a circulatory system in
the sense that animals have it
nonetheless the plant is an integrated
whole and you know you've had the
experience of taking a perkin violet
leaf of a plant and putting it in water
well it doesn't spread more leaves at
the bottom it sprouts roots that polar
auxin transport integrates the whole
plant consistently so it's a unified
structure the whole thing yes duvets
we're all very different almost alien
plants are fair now sees me that all
your exams are flowering plants are
there big differences between them and
the flowering plants are the most highly
evolved ones and yes there are
differences and yes there are major
similarities many plants these higher
plants for example have a very reduced
that plants have a haploid generation a
diploid generation they have cells that
have chromosomes from both parents and
other cells that have only one copy of
every chromosome that's for next lecture
but in many lower plants those are
actually different plants very different
forms and that's not true in higher
plants that's an example of a very big
difference think of mosses and lichens
those are creatures that are still
related to plants but very much farther
down the evolutionary scale there
they're not even recognizable as as it
they don't look like higher plants and
they metabolize differently but there
again commonalities through all of life
animal and plant life and what unifies
plants is the ability to photosynthesize
yes what happens when you take say
Hindle interrogation which is synthetic
does it
yep this is another small molecule and
it does get taken it I can't guarantee
that that particular one I and I would
have to see whether that particular ones
been studied mm-hmm right yes boy that's
a question I'm not a much I'm not is up
on that aspect of evolution as I should
and I don't think i could give you a
really good answer about the origin of
flowers yes well I touch on the concept
of memory oh gosh probably not a lot but
I can talk to you afterwards I don't
want to keep everybody see that
questions already been asked one more
and then we'll let you go
the sleep-wake cycle about 25 hours
is there a similar change in the
freerunning rhythm probably and I can't
answer I don't know specifically so
that's not a question I can answer
detail I could find the answer but I'm
sure it's been measured hold your plants
to what they say well okay I didn't go
into that much but the point is if you
think about the other things I said
about electrons running around they have
to restructure their metabolism
completely they turn off photosynthesis
and they they spend the day collecting
energy and storing they synthesize
sugars the sugars are converted into
starch which is a polymer of sugars at
night they do what you do that is they
respire and they break down sugars is a
huge huge change in the metabolism of
plant from day to night thank you very
much for your attention
you